now this is a story we first brought you
last week a man fighting covid 19 in a
hospital bed for more than a hundred
days faced with just a massive bill yeah
but after our victoria saha got involved
the medical group dropped the majority
of the tens of thousands of dollars he'd
been charged james sweeney and his son
scott cannot breathe a sigh of relief
it's the best feeling we've probably had
since he's woken up you know because
it's it's been that stressful earlier
this month james faced a 80 thousand
dollar bill from sound intensivists a
private medical group contracted with
his in-network hospital that's where he
was staying while unconscious and on a
ventilator trouble is the doctors at the
hospital are out of network i would have
to dip in to my 401k maybe even a
pension
just to be able to
make the minimum payments james still
made out of pocket payments still
overwhelmed the sweeney's reached out to
eight news now last week after we aired
his story the company reached out to
james wanting to resolve the issue right
away after originally telling him it
would take a few weeks to investigate by
tuesday morning his bill dropped to 8200
you got the ball rolling during this
time his insurance paid james close to
ten thousand dollars of that original
eighty thousand dollar bill sound
intensivist has now agreed to take just
that portion dropping the rest by
tuesday afternoon james had paid his
bill in full i want to thank you and
your team for doing everything you have
done victoria saha live local now now
victoria had questions for the
spokesperson for sound intensivists like
who is picking up the remainder of mr
sweeney's bill or if they can confirm
with the hospital on patients insurance
status before treating them they
declined to answer those questions but
they released a statement it says in
part we also actively negotiate with
insurance plans to ensure we are
receiving the appropriate rates for
services at this time sound has reached
successful resolution of the account in
question spokesperson for sound
physicians is the person who sent in
that statement denise